Éste es otro de los problemas que me mandó
Cortagio, el cual es bastante interesante,
al igual que los otros 2 y de igual manera,
vas a ver que se soluciona de una forma bastante
parecida a los otros dos y es justo lo que
quiero, que vayas creando una intuición
de cómo se resuelven estos problemas, pero bueno,
¿qué dice el problema?
Alicia está a 100 metros de Blanca
y Blanca está a 300 metros de Carlos
y justo es lo que quiero que veas.
Alicia es la letra A,
Blanca va a ser la letra B
y Carlos va a ser la letra C.
Así que vamos a ponerlo en un diagrama.
Alicia está a 100 metros de Blanca y Blanca
está a 300 metros de carlos y voy a suponer
que Blanca está a la derecha de Carlos
y por lo tanto, aquí tenemos a Alicia,
por acá tenemos a Blanca
y por acá tenemos a Carlos a 300 metros de Blanca.
Y de hecho la distancia de Alicia a Blanca
es de 100 metros,
esto va a ser bastante importante,
por lo tanto déjenme ponerla
de un color distinto
y la distancia de Blanca a Carlos
es de 300 metros.
Y después dice, todos se encuentran
viendo hacia el frente y en la misma línea,
entonces en la misma línea ya están,
pero además todos se tienen que
encontrar viendo hacia al frente,
entonces todos ven hacia el frente,
Alicia está viendo en esta dirección,
Blanca está viendo en esta dirección
y Carlos también.
Y después dice, todos ellos viajan hacia
el frente a velocidades constantes,
y bueno, no forzosamente
tienen que tener la misma velocidad,
así que voy a decir que Alicia
va a una velocidad
"V" subíndice "a",
Blanca va a una velocidad
"V" subíndice "b"
y Carlos va a una velocidad
"V" subíndice "c".
Y después dice, en 6 minutos,
Alicia alcanza a Blanca,
entonces
¿cómo podemos pasar esta oración a una ecuación?
Bueno, vamos a hablar de distancia, la distancia
que recorre Alicia en 6 minutos,
tienen que ser igual a la distancia
que recorre Blanca en 6 minutos,
más los 100 metros que había de diferencia.
¿Cómo podemos escribir eso?
Bueno, utilizando la fórmula de la velocidad,
voy a decir que la velocidad de Alicia por el tiempo,
es decir, la distancia que recorre Alicia en 6 minutos, esto tiene que ser igual
a 100 metros que es la distancia que había
entre Alicia y Blanca
más la distancia que ha recorrido Blanca
en estos 6 minutos,
es decir,
la velocidad de Blanca por 6,
porque pasaron 6 minutos y Alicia alcanzó a Blanca,
esto es lo que me dice la primera ecuación,
pero después dice que en otros 6 minutos,
6 minutos después, Alicia también alcanza a Carlos,
en los siguientes 6 minutos,
Alicia rebasa a Carlos y bueno,
si escribo eso de la misma manera en ecuaciones,
pues me va a quedar algo muy parecido.
Fíjate bien, hablemos de distancia,
date cuenta que 6 minutos más 6 minutos,
estoy hablando de 12 minutos,
entonces la distancia que recorre Alicia en 12 minutos,
tiene que ser igual a 100 más 300,
es decir, 400 metros tuvo que recorrer Alicia
para estar en el punto donde empezó Carlos, entonces, esto va a ser igual a 400
más la distancia que haya recorrido Carlos,
es decir, la velocidad de Carlos por el tiempo,
pero el tiempo son 12 minutos,
la velocidad de Carlos...
de Carlos, no de Alicia, perdón,
perdón perdón...
La velocidad de Carlos, por el tiempo
y aquí ya tengo otra ecuación, ojo,
las dos ecuaciones hablan de la distancia.
Y ahora veamos qué nos preguntan,
¿en cuántos minutos Blanca
logrará rebasar a Carlos?
Y justo tras esto vamos, pero
¿habrá forma de escribir esta pregunta de una manera que nos resulte una ecuación?
Y pues la respuesta es que sí,
utilizando la misma idea,
nosotros lo que buscamos es el tiempo,
pero si Blanca va a alcanzar a Carlos,
entonces tiene que pasar lo siguiente,
Blanca tiene que recorrer una cierta distancia
para llegar hasta Carlos.
¿Y cómo podemos escribir eso?
Bueno, pues la velocidad de Blanca por el
tiempo, este tiempo que estoy buscando,
justo mi incógnita, tiene que ser igual
a qué distancia hay entre Blanca y Carlos,
son 300 metros por lo tanto esto tiene que ser igual
a 300 metros para llegar al punto inicial de Carlos,
más lo que haya recorrido Carlos,
es decir, la velocidad de Carlos por el tiempo,
pero por el mismo tiempo, por mi incógnita.
Y entonces, si entendemos bien,
qué es lo que está pasando,
ya podemos despejar de aquí al tiempo,
¿y qué quiere decir esto?
Que Alicia va a alcanzar a Blanca
y si Alicia va a alcanzar a Blanca,
entonces tienen que recorrer 100 metros,
más lo que haya avanzado Blanca.
Y después Alicia va a alcanzar a Carlos,
entonces Alicia tiene que recorrer 400 metros
más lo que haya avanzado Carlos y si Blanca
va a alcanzar a Carlos, entonces tiene que
recorrer 300 metros, más todo lo que haya
avanzado Carlos en este mismo tiempo.
Y bueno, siguiendo esta idea,
voy a despejar a lo que yo quiero, es decir al tiempo,
y para estoy voy a pasar la velocidad de Carlos
por el tiempo del otro lado de la ecuación
con signo contrario, entonces me queda la
velocidad de Blanca por el tiempo, menos la
velocidad de Carlos por el tiempo,
es igual a 300 de esta ecuación
y si ahora factorizo el tiempo,
¿qué me va a quedar?
Que la velocidad de Blanca
menos la velocidad de Carlos,
esto multiplicado por el tiempo
tiene que ser igual a 300,
lo único que estoy haciendo
es factorizando al tiempo.
Y ahora si,
si yo quiero despejar al tiempo,
¿qué tengo que hacer?
Pues pasar dividiendo esto que está al lado del tiempo  y me va a quedar que 300
entre la velocidad de Blanca menos la velocidad de Carlos, tiene que ser igual al tiempo
y es justo lo que yo quiero y espero que pueda encontrar una expresión equivalente
para la velocidad de Blanca
menos la velocidad de Carlos,
utilizando estas otras
dos ecuaciones que tengo.
De cada una de estas ecuaciones,
voy a despejar a la velocidad de Blanca en la primera
y a la velocidad de Carlos en la segunda, esperando
que se pueda cancelar, la velocidad de Alicia,
creo que por ahí voy a resolver el problema,
tengo la intuición de que por ahí puedo
encontrar la solución del problema,
cancelando la velocidad de Alicia y es más,
creo que si no puedo cancelar la velocidad de Alicia,
el problema no tiene solución.
Así que de la primera ecuación,
despejemos la velocidad de Blanca
para sustituirla en mi ecuación del tiempo,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
Que 6 veces la velocidad de Blanca, esto tiene
que ser igual a 6 veces la velocidad de Alicia
y después si ahora yo divido ambos lados
de la ecuación entre 6 para encontrar el
valor exacto de la velocidad de Blanca,
me va a quedar que esto es igual a 6 entre 6,
esto me da solamente la velocidad de Alicia
menos 100 entre 6, lo cual es 50/3
pero lo voy a dejar como 100 entre 6
porque ahorita lo voy a ocupar.
Ahora, de esta segunda ecuación,
voy a despejar a la velocidad de Carlos
en términos de la velocidad de Alicia,
para que así pueda sustituirla también
en mi ecuación del tiempo
y entonces,
¿qué me queda?
12 veces la velocidad de Carlos,
es igual a 12 veces la velocidad de Alicia,
menos 400 y de igual manera
voy a dividir todo entre 12
y entonces me queda que la velocidad de
Carlos es igual a la velocidad de Alicia menos
400 entre 12 y creo que sí me va a salir
el problema porque de aquí,
ya estoy viendo que
sí se va a cancelar la velocidad de Alicia,
así que vamos a sustituir la velocidad de Blanca aquí, vamos a sustituir la velocidad de Carlos aquí
y vamos a ver a qué llego,
que por cierto, hay que recordar siempre qué
es lo que queremos, lo que queremos es el
tiempo en el cual Blanca va a rebasar a Carlos,
siempre es importante saber qué es lo que
queremos y no olvidarlo, así que vamos a
sustituir estos 2 y me queda,
la velocidad de Blanca, pero la velocidad de Blanca es
igual a la velocidad de Alicia
menos 100 sobre 6, entonces la velocidad de Alicia menos 100, sobre 6
y a esto hay que quitarle
la velocidad de Carlos,
pero la velocidad de Carlos es igual a la velocidad de Alicia menos 400 entre 12...
la velocidad de Alicia menos 400 entre 12...
y hay que tener cuidad
con este paréntesis
y ahora, ya que tengo esto,
voy a distribuir este signo de menos,
¿y qué me queda?
300 entre la velocidad de Alicia,
menos 100 sobre 6,
100 sobre 6 es lo mismo que 50 entre 3,
entonces mejor lo voy a poner como 50/3
y a esto le voy a restar la velocidad de Alicia...
¡Perfecto! éstas dos se van a cancelar,
justo lo que quería.
Menos por menos me da más
y 400 entre 2 es lo mismo que 200 entre 6,
que es lo mismo que 100, entre 3,
entonces más 100 entre 3
y esto va a ser igual,
¿a cuánto?
Estos dos se van,
que es justo lo que yo quería,
la velocidad de Alicia
menos la velocidad de Alicia se van,
no las necesito y esto es
igual a 300 entre -50/3 más 100/3,
es lo mismo que 100/3 menos 50/3,
que es lo mismo que 50/3,
entonces de estos dos me queda 50/3
y sí voy bien...
300 entre...
100/3 menos 50/3...
sí, sí, sí, es 50/3, aquí vamos todo en
orden y entonces,
¿qué me va a quedar de esto?
Bueno,
al dividir un número entre una fracción,
es lo mismo que multiplicar ese número
por el recíproco de la fracción
y me queda esta expresión que tengo aquí,
300 entre 50, se puede simplificar bastante,
300 entre 50 es lo mismo que 6, entonces esto
es 6, aquí me queda un 1 y 6 por 3 es 18,
¡y ya encontré el tiempo que yo quería!
El tiempo son 18 minutos que esa era justo
la unidad que estábamos trabajando,
por lo tanto,
el tiempo en el que alcanza Blanca a Carlos,
es 18 minutos y ya reencontré este problema,
¿y cómo lo encontré?
De una manera muy mágica y tal vez estratosférica,
porque si hacemos las cosas bien,
date cuenta que en el problema tarde o temprano
se va a cancelar una de las variables que yo quiero
y me va a quedar todo en términos
de puros valores numéricos.
Si utilizas la información que te da el problema
y además sustituyes las variables correctas,
entonces vas a encontrar la solución
de una manera muy sencilla.
Intenta resolver los problemas
siempre por esta misma manera.
Y muchas gracias a Cortagio
por mandarnos este problema.